et
[Musique]
événement
24 vous fait vivre l'élection
présidentielle française
cette année le président mâcon sera-t-il
réélu pour cinq ans ou sera-t-il battu
par l'un des candidats déterminés à le
faire tomber
france24 ouvre la campagne électorale et
va à la rencontre des français des
candidats et de leurs soutiens
suivez l'élection présidentielle
française tous les jours sur france 24
et france 24 points comme
salut à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce quatrième live c'est le
complément de notre émission france 2022
l'heure du choix consacrez vous le savez
à la présidentielle en france cela et
vous c'est votre moment à vous les
internautes n'hésitez pas vous poser à
nous poser toutes les questions donc sur
les enjeux de cette présidentielle sur
les coulisses de notre émission sur
comment on réalise les reportages sur
voilà les grands enjeux de cette
campagne vous le savez en état à six
jours du premier tour donc on imagine
que vos questions sont très nombreuses
donc posez nous toutes ces questions sur
le facebook live le youtube là et des
grâces comme d'habitude à notre équipe
mobilisée ici en région va recueillir
toutes ces questions et on va essayer de
répondre à un maximum d'entre vous alors
avant de retrouver roselyne febvre vous
la connaissez maintenant la chef du
service politique de france 24 qui nous
rejoindra donc d'ici une quinzaine une
vingtaine de minutes je suis tout
d'abord avec ma collègue la journaliste
et reporter karina jabour qui couvre
donc cette campagne présidentielle pour
france24 salut karina ça va bien ça que
je prenne son avion tout d'abord karina
pour entre guillemets de présenter aux
internautes qui sont déjà nombreux est
ce que tu peux expliquer comment tu
travaille au quotidien qu'est ce que
c'est pour toi de couvrir cette campagne
commence passe une journée type donc
deux mois du coup je suis donc reporter
sur cette campagne donc je suis chargé
de raconter enfin de suivre une
candidate en particulier valérie
pécresse donc ça veut dire et bien me
rendent par exemple au congrès le jour
où elle a gagné elle de la primaire elle
a été désignée comme étant le rail
descendant
c'était voilà c'était début décembre
dernier ça veut dire être avec elle sur
des déplacements c'était le cas mardi
dernier où elle reprenait à sa campagne
après avoir
attrapé l'écho vide et ça veut dire
effectivement suivre son meeting par
exemple celui de cette semaine ou de
celui du zénith donc c'est que je puisse
d'en raconter comment ça se passe
l'ambiance échanger avec des supporters
des militants ou avec son équipe lui
poser des questions aussi directement
voilà je suis plus dans le raconter
moins dans l'analyse peut-être même si
et bien on peut établir des comparaisons
on peut sur une année sur l'autre voire
l'évolution que si on a une une certaine
et puis on est à france 24 donc on est
une petite équipe de reporters il ya
aussi des contraintes qui sont très
fortes depuis la semaine dernière
j'allais venir dans la pratique tu
couvres aussi d'autres peut être me
donner il ya des tas couvert emmanuel
macron également mal mâcon c'était il ya
cinq ans je les couverts mais disons que
là il faut s'adapter puisque on est sur
un système d'égalité de temps de parole
et ben c'est que j'ai été amené à parler
par exemple
là ce soir par exemple de fabien roussel
le candidat communiste je vais aller
dans un de ces apéros celle avec des
militants pour justement voir quand ils
essayent de se démarquer comme il essaye
d'exister dans cette campagne avec ce
côté bon enfant
apéro pains parlant politique
gastronomie pouvoir d'achat etc et puis
et puis aussi parler d'autres petits
candidats
la semaine dernière attend déjà un trou
de mémoire de qui on a parlé d' idées
trop vite
[Rires]
ça va me revenir ce candidat un peu
farfelue que genre la salle jean
lassalle exactement et qui que j'avais
interviewé ya cinq ans qui ne m'avait je
me souviens semblait très sympathique et
comment dire atypique rigolo et qui en
fait au fil du temps est plus obscur
aujourd'hui disons qu'il a une phase un
peu plus obscures depuis cinq ans il est
un peu multiplié des propos complotistes
il a aussi entretenu des relations un
peu bizarre avec
des gens pas très recommande à bachar al
assad c'est un peu l'idée de faire un
éclairage à la semaine dernière donc on
a un petit peu multi multi tâches donc
tu l'évoqué karina c'est pas ta première
campagne tu vas couvert notamment celle
d'il ya cinq ans est-ce que tu constates
disons une atmosphère particulière faire
quelque chose qui te marque cette année
par rapport aux autres campagnes que tu
as pu couvrir dans le passé alors
effectivement j'ai conversé le 10 à 5
ans et c'est vraiment le jour et la nuit
parce que ne serait ce qu'en termes de
couverture et en terme de campagne
proprement dite il ya cinq ans on avait
quand même un gros dispositif je sais
pas si tu te souviens mais les grands
partis traditionnels qui était foutue
sont encore à moindre échelle les
républicains ont les partis socialistes
avaient organisé une primaire un
primaires de la gauche avec d'autres
partis et primaire de la droite on a
découvert ça on avait plusieurs
dispositifs moi j'étais allée notamment
avec des militants de saint nicolas
sarkozy et puis de françois fillon
et puis ça a été une surprise souvenez
vous il y avait quand même un souriant
thouars qu'il y avait quand même pas mal
de têtes d'affiché à l'époque qui ont
complètement disparu aujourd'hui de lier
de la surface la vie politique alain
juppé nicolas sarkozy françois fillon
nathalie kosciusko morizet et pas mal de
surprises dont françois fillon qui
l'avait emporté dont il y avait beaucoup
de suspense il y avait des personnages
anciens connus etc et c'est un petit peu
comme un là dessus est arrivé emmanuel
macron de nulle part au début c'était
pas mal de curiosité aussi pas mal de
peut-être de condescendance en se disant
mais il a aucun ancrage local il a aucun
soutien il n'y arrivera jamais
maintenant finalement et j'avais suivi
justement j'avais fait le tout premier
meeting de avant même qu'ils soient
candidats d' emmanuel macron donc il y
avait pas mal de suspense une grosse
couverture on avait vraiment suivi
toutes les primaires on avait fait tous
les meetings
donc françois fillon je vous rappelle
qu'ils avaient dû insister pour
concourir au premier tour et puis il
avait été rattrapé par les affaires
finalement il avait perdu au premier
tour et ensuite bon ben j'ai fait toute
la campagne c'était vraiment un tour de
france on le suivait donc encore on la
suivait très réduite
avec beaucoup moins de rebondissements
avec wii fit a finalement
problème de on va y venir et puis en
plus une cause de la diversion mais
c'est en partie ce qui explique
aujourd'hui un électeur sur trois n'est
même pas sûr d'aller voter et là sur
quatre se nommer mais juste un exemple
au lendemain le jour même de de ce
congrès les républicains ou valérie
pécresse l'a emporté première première
déclaration avant même de donner le
résultat du responsable du parti c'était
de dire le meeting annoncé pour la
semaine prochaine finalement se tiendra
en visioconférence évidemment ça donne
envie le colis qui a empêché des
déplacements et puis là dessus la guerre
en ukraine qui a clairement mais tout
écraser alors
deux
bill bmc sur instagram karina d'après
les sondages quel candidat a le plus de
chances de l'emporter beaucoup de
questions apparemment sur donc les
derniers sondages tout simplement massa
ça renvoie finalement un petit peu au
manque d'intérêt de cette campagne c'est
que sont donnés gagnants emmanuel macron
marine le pen les deux mêmes qu'en 2017
et c'est brixia tour match retour
voilà on n'avait pas beaucoup d'
enthousiasme et les seuls peut-être
élément nouveau t2 une de cette campagne
2022 c'était peut-être en amont enfin
eric zemmour qui a commencé très fort et
qui a fait sa tournée dédicaces etc et
qui était un peu l'élément de nouveautés
et puis à peut-être à gauche c'était une
primaire populaire organisée par
beaucoup de jeunes et de figures de
gauche et écologistes qui essayait
justement de le déterminer un candidat
de gauche capable de battre justement
d'empêcher ce duel annoncé et finalement
non finalement à six jours du premier
tour ils sont effectivement donné donné
gagnant et jean luc mélenchon serait
troisième inscrit alors tu étais hier au
meeting va au grand meeting de valérie
pécresse dont porte de versailles c'est
symbolique un pur pour la droite tu vas
tu vas nous en parler un exercice
indéniablement beaucoup plus réussi qu
zénith en même temps on partait d'assez
loin à la était quand même très critiqué
pour cette performance tant sur le fond
que sur la forme
même si l'exercice là au zénith ou à la
porte de versailles était réussie c'est
quand même un peu tard remonter la pente
malgré cinquième dans les intentions des
dommages fin entre entre guillemets
c'est que ce ce meeting à la porte de
versailles sur la forme il était
beaucoup plus sous dimensionné que celui
du zénith il y avait je crois que près
5000 personnes et 8000 au zénith le
zénith est quand même une grosse envie
de casser un simple ses imposants comme
ça c'est sûr plusieurs fins sur
plusieurs niveaux avec une énorme scène
est en fait la réflexion que qu'on peut
se faire c'est pourquoi ils ont pas
commencé par la porte de versailles où
elle était sur une petite estrade quasi
long de chauffe voilà juste un tour de
chauffe et hier effectivement c'était
beaucoup plus réussi en tout cas elle
semblait beaucoup plus à l'aise sont ont
elles été beaucoup plus naturelle elle a
dominé la salle comme comme on dit ce
qui était absolument pas le cas au
zénith donc on peut se poser la question
pourquoi ils n'ont pas inversé je pense
que c'est vraiment une erreur
stratégique et je pense que c'est son
entourage beaucoup d'hommes entre
guillemets qui ont voulu calquer ce
qu'avait fait nicolas sarkozy en 2007
sauf qu elle l était pas prête à ça ça a
été un chemin de croix au week-end pour
toi ah oui oui clairement parce que même
le jour de l'annoncé qu'on pense d'elle
elle est quand même un gars de l'afaspa
elle essaie de garder on peut dire
qu'elle est pour ajourner le combatif
mais c'est vrai que le jour où on
annonce sa victoire
à la primaire des républicains où ils
affichent cette image de familles
réunies à la halle parle dès qu'il a dit
hier aussi à l'équipe de france est de
retour
mais quelques heures après je crois eric
ciotti don qui est un des perdants de
cette primaire
dit sur une antenne le discours de
valérie pécresse n'était pas un bon
discours vains les dissensions
commencent par ce que lui ou savait qu
il incarne une ligne beaucoup plus
droitière et voulait absolument qu'elle
reprenne à son compte ces idées très
très ferme sur notamment l'immigration
la sécurité donc dès le premier jour
dissensions après on a vu plein de
défection des figures importantes des
républicains qui sont partis chez makro
beaucoup d'électeurs sans parti
également chez makro ou chez eric
zemmour à la sortie du congrès du zénith
j'en entendais qui me disaient non mais
elle n'est pas assez à droite alors
qu'on sait qu'elle a repris cette
expression de la bouche fin des
complotistes ou d'eric zemmour de grand
remplacement donc mais me disais
maintenant elle est pas elle fait du
soulier moore donc moi je pense que je
vais aller voter pour eric zemmour et
puis là dessus by lm c'est l'attrapé
cowitz à l'arrivée de déplacements
importants en fin de semaine dernière
jusqu'à jusqu'à mardi dernier donc elle
a eu une succession des critiques
extrêmement vive et même sur sa personne
et là franchement je trouve qu'il ya eu
à un moment ça m'a rappelé ségolène
royal en 2007 où il ya eu un côté
misogyne fin des attaques personnelles
super mal venue mardi dernier donc
j'étais avec elle quand elle est allée à
marcq en baroeul dans la banlieue
lilloise et pourtant exercice qui devait
être simple rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprise dans une antenne un peu
genre medef où elle s'adresse à des
chefs d'entreprise une sorte d'animateur
de chauffeur de salle qui lui pose des
questions mais des questions qui étaient
vraiment très mal placé et qui se serait
absolument pas permis de poser si ça
avait été un homme du style commence à
se dire comment votre mari vit le fait
que vous soyez candidate à la
présidentielle et qui lui a rejoué la
vidéo vous savez où elle dit rien de
mieux qu'une femme pour pour faire le
ménage sur ses terres une vidéo du petit
journal où effectivement c'est une
bourde mais hélas pour le coup j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a vraiment fondu
l'armure cela elle s'est énervée elle
était exaspérée et l ua
et c'est leur finale c'est la montée
n'est pas toujours comme ça en fait
est-ce qu'on a l'impression qu'elle
s'excuse toujours et qu'elle est
tiraillé entre eric ciotti ou exavier
bertrand allait elle est prise en
tenaille avec ses ténors qui qui lui
oblige à parler de ça là quand elle est
vraiment elle-même on partage on partage
pas ses idées ne s'est pas loupé c'est
pas le respect de principes mais en tout
cas elle est naturelle et elle a
carrément rembarré en lui disant mais
qui n'a pas fait de bourde ces douze
dernières années et c'est vrai que voilà
dans ces cas là est la marque des points
en tout cas alors un grand dida qui lui
est beaucoup plus tribun dirons nous là
aussi indéniablement quoi qu'on pense de
lui on a une question de me regarde
dembélé
karina qui nous tombent donc est ce que
jean luc mélenchon à mélenchon a une
chance tu couvres passage en face à caen
selon les intentions de vote il est il
est donné troisième il est donné
troisième il ya quand même une petite
marge encore
ce qu'il a ce qu'il a une chance c'est
vrai que
le problème entre guillemets de jean luc
mélenchon s'il a un aspect clivant et
qu' il est fâché enfin c'est la première
fois depuis quinze ans que par exemple
le candidat communiste fait sa propre
campagne et non pas avec la france 1
somistes qu'il comprit y compris au sein
de la gauche il n'a pas réussi à
rassembler et je pense que ça va être
juste juste pour vous qu'il puisse
gagner il va lui manquer des voix de la
gauche et va lui manquer voilà toujours
souvent des batailles d'ego d'ailleurs
jean-luc mélenchon qui va faire un grand
meeting demain mardi à hologram il faut
dire l'avant en matière numérique il a
une bonne équipe aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux on parle beaucoup à la jeunesse
le week-end dernier autres grands
meetings celui d' emmanuel macron a sans
doute peut-être même le sol de cette de
cette campagne
un grand meeting aux allures de match de
foot on sent quand même pas mal de
fébrilité ces derniers jours au sein des
macros nist qui voit bien marine le pen
donc la candidate du rassemblement
national à konya d'extrême droite
resserrer l'écart avec le président
sortant non mais effectivement il ya eu
un vent frémissement la semaine dernière
en tout cas une sorte de ventes panique
au sein de deux proches des manuels ma
chronique
vous dire il a démarré très tard la
compagnie dont il occupe son poste de
chef d'état et chef de guerre qui
d'ailleurs est plutôt à son avantage de
ce point de vue là mais effectivement il
ya eu la ferme acquise et dont on a pas
mal parlé la semaine dernière qui ne me
dessert parce que ça le rend voilà
l'image dont il a essayé voilà il a
essayé de s'en défaire ça lui a collé à
la peau ça pas été bon au moment de la
crise des gilet jaune mais un président
à la méprise en méprise président des
riches de la start-up nichane
complètement déconnecté des réalités de
tout le monde et puis il ya aussi son
annonce deux programmes il ya une
semaine à peu près où on a retenu deux
mesures quasiment piqué d'ailleurs à
valérie pécresse celle de la retraite à
65 ans il ne s'est pas privé le lien
absolument agir de voix de fausset
et le rsa le revenu de solidarité active
sous condition donc là il a vraiment
cherché à redresser la barre plus à
gauche pendant ce meeting meeting qui
devrait vous l'avez dit c'est moi ça m'a
vraiment j étais pas mais le ppe-de
images que j'ai vues ça faisait vraiment
le one man show le vraiment le seul en
scène à l'américaine et ça contraste est
pas mal avec le meeting de valérie
pécresse où elles les ont ils ont
vraiment sûr joué hier le côté équipe de
france il ya une quinzaine de ténors de
personnalités de la société civile pour
pécresse qui se sont succédé sur la
scène et qui ont tous avec tous avaient
le même discours c'est à dire macro
bilan négatif
comédiens
méprisant qui n'écoutent pas qui ne
débat pas qui ne veut pas débattre avec
nous là où valérie pécresse elle est là
un projet sérieux budgété elle fera les
vraies réformes et ce ne sera pas du
plagiat ce sera du sérieux merci
beaucoup karina d'avoir répondu aux
questions nos internautes merci à vous
tous d'en avoir posé à karina je te
laisse donc repartir caréna mais bonne
fin de campagne adversaire sera à
nouveau thé thé reportage à retrouver
bien évidemment sur le site de france 24
france 24 points comme merci au revoir
car henin merci à vous qui nous
rejoignent est peut-être à l'instant
même dans ce facebook live et youtube
laddh consacré à la présidentielle en
france je vous le rappelle j - 6 avant
le premier tour c'est donc la dernière
ligne droite pour les candidats pour
tenter de convaincre la masse des
électeurs
toujours indécis un électeur sur quatre
selon les derniers sondages un électeur
sur trois mêmes envisage de ne pas se
déplacer le jour j et l'abstention donc
ça non ce record un constat qui inquiète
un quel que soit le bord politique quel
que soit le candidat et maya anaïs seuil
est à guaino a maintenant rejoint salut
maillard donc maya est l'une de mes
collègues très proche qui fait partie
intégrante de notre team présidentielle
maya du côté du coup anglophone de
l'équivalent de france 2020 de l'heure
du choix c'est franz twenty one thing to
do campaign donc voila tu es la
coordinatrice de cette émission et tu
réalises aussi beaucoup de reportages de
terrain les week-ends même la nuit un
parfois
voilà mayall tradition
maya alors toi alors karina on
l'évoquait elle était au meeting de
valérie pécresse hier toi tu étais au
meeting de anne hidalgo
c'était quoi l'atmosphère avec fadil
wyatt exact notre autre collègue
c'était une atmosphère c'est un peu
alors déjà ses chants du jeu ouais
c'était au cercle au cirque d'hiver
pardon à paris
c'est un très bel endroit c'était plein
il y avait plein de monde c'était
c'était super avait une bonne ambiance
se sentait que les gens étaient étaient
chauffés en bleu et blanc et en même
temps il y avait une petite tape
mosphere tristan n'apparaît pas mal de
gens qui disaient c'est pas gagné il
était vraiment dans l'incompréhension
faut pas gagné elle est donc on le
rappelle à 2% environ dans les
intentions de vote la candidate du parti
socialiste essaie historiquement
césaire hier même donc le candidat du
parti communiste un fabien roussel et ça
s'était jamais arrivé c'est ça qui est
fou d'allah on a eu cette discussion là
à quel moment et ce qu'on considère anne
hidalgo comme un petit parti un petit
candidat à quel moment est ce qu'on
considère qu anne hidalgo qui fait
effectivement 2% sont les sondages et
une petite candidate alors qu'il ya tout
l'appareil du ps on sent que ce meeting
qui est plutôt bien organisé alors
savait pas le faste des meeting de
françois hollande qui pouvait aller à
bercy ou qui pouvaient aller dans des
endroits vraiment gigantesque en 2017 en
2012 pardon pour son élection forcément
là c'est un plus petit endroit ce qui
était aussi très marquant c'était le
fait qu' il ya très peu de tête
d'affiche socialiste que au final les
socialistes de premier rang tenait sur
une rangée une rangée de marlyse
socialiste on pense déjà à l'après au
signe clairement clairement que ce soit
dans nos interviews ou chez nous ou chez
d'autres journalistes on sent qu'ils
sont ils sont la tête dans les
législatives olivier faur qu'on a qu'on
a interviewé le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
clic voilà il sait qu'il peut perdre que
le coup d'après ces législatives et même
une petite musique de recomposition que
ce soit avec françois hollande toujours
lui qui dit qu'il veut refaire une force
de gauche ou avec d'autres d'autres
chefs de partis sont pas tous partis
chez chez makro ils sont pas touchées
mais l'enfant est en train de se dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait du ps après
l'échéance électorale du premier tour tu
as fait beaucoup d'autres reportages un
maya notamment auprès des écologistes
dernièrement donc l'équipe de yannick
jadot
pas mal de questions de nos internautes
nous mêmes d'ailleurs on se pose la
question pourquoi est ce que ce thème
pourtant si brûlant l'actualité de
l'écologie et de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique en tout cas le
combat climatique pourquoi est-ce que ce
thème n'a pas pris dans cette campagne
et c'est notamment une question de teva
jarre b ou garbay qui nous pose cette
question sur instagram pourquoi
l'écologie ne prend toujours pas dans
cette campagne merci beaucoup at t va
garder pour la question c'est vrai que
ça semble dingue on a on a le rapport du
giec on a des jours rtt ça ouais on se
dit ok le climat d'alger à lyon d'ici
2100 ça commence vraiment à chauffer
littéralement et dans les manifs pour le
climat ils le disent on est plus choc le
climat j'étais à la manif look up notre
look up et j'étais aussi au meeting de
jado le grand meeting où il était très
fier dans le plus grand meeting de
l'écologie politique en france ils ont
eu récemment des succès ce soit sur les
européennes ou sur les régionales mais
un présidentielle ça marche pas ça
marche vraiment pas c'est très
certainement lié au mode de scrutin au
fait que l'élection présidentielle
demande un parti à ses formes en tout
cas une personnalité capable de
récupérer des gens de partie avec une
expérience politique et là les verts
depuis les années soixante dix savent
pas faire ça issaly
au parti socialiste en général en 2017
il y va de la paix fait d'ailleurs été
retiré au profit de benoît hamon cette
année il y va il pensait certainement
que c'était son moment et non non non ça
l'était pas tu as aussi couverts pas mal
de petits candidats notamment les
trotskistes
c'est une spécificité française ces
candidats d'extrême gauche à la
présidentielle cette année il y en a
même deux donc philippe poutou du
nouveau parti
anticapitaliste jamais le dire et
nathalie arthaud de lutte ouvrière
on sait bien que il pense pas remporté
sérieusement la présidentielle c'est
quoi pour eux et pour leurs militants et
pour les gens à qui tu as pu parler
durant ton reportage c'est quoi le sens
pour de cette
présence dans la campagne tu dis très
bien qu' il ne pense pas gagner je
rajouterais même que certains ne veulent
pas gagner ils sont dans l'élection mais
on sait pour tout faire péter ils
prennent l'elysée tout en disant à quoi
ça servirait donc en réalité ils veulent
wifi les poteaux d'ailleurs le candidat
du npa veut même
supprimé la fonction présidentielle
ce serait même sa première mesure c'est
vrai que ce serait agréable certains ont
touché au salaire du président lui
vivent carrément toucher à cette
fonction présidentielle et la supprimer
donc et d'ailleurs on parlait d'un
hidalgo qui était au cirque d'hiver
quand j'y suis allé j'ai pris le métro
et je marchais sur des petits stickers
d'une paire parce que la veille au
cirque d'hiver c'était philippe poutou
qui faisait son meeting c'est aussi
intéressant de voir en terme de
l'audience qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui parti socialiste par rapport
au npa comme une personne c'est
l'inversé
alors je n'étais pas au meeting de
philippe poutou dont je peux pas donner
mon ressenti personnel je veux pas
d'ailleurs de donner de chiffre exact
c'est quelqu'un les amnésies tepa le
médecin
mais en tout cas pendant il est pendant
son discours il expliquait que oui il le
sait avec les règles du temps de parole
balle là on est dans la période d'
égalité stricte forcément on va devenir
compliqué pour nous et puis on essaye de
le faire à la perfection faire la
seconde présent c'est vrai mais c'est en
tant que double casquette un peu franco
anglo vive l'anglo génial ya pas de
temps
n'est pas n'a pas les mêmes contraintes
exactement donc donc là on n'a pas ça
mais bon après je fais les sujets dans
les deux langues donc trois minutes avec
les trotskistes ses enfants qu est en
anglais mais donc ça leur permet de
donner une visibilité à leur combat même
si ils le disent très bien même ils sont
tout le temps là en fait c'est juste une
prolongation leur combat local de
terrain tout le temps ils ont très
présent dans les hôpitaux dans les
universités avec les travailleurs c'est
le slogan notamment attendus par arlette
laguiller l'après qui était avant
nathalie arthaud pour mener le parti
lutte ouvrière travailleurs
travailleuses ils sont là à leurs côtés
et quand ils arrivent à la
présidentielle ils redisent exactement
la même chose pour mettre fin au système
capitaliste autres reportages de terrain
que tu veux faire un bayern a fait
décidément beaucoup et vous pouvez
d'ailleurs tous les retrouver sur le
site internet de france 24 à la fois en
français et en anglais
donc donc autre reportage maya auprès
des anti vax au sein des cortèges un
autre candidat donc que nico le
souverainiste nicolas dupont aignan
même question c'est quoi leur sentiment
face et quoi l'atmosphère un petit peu
c'est quoi le l'état d'esprit des
antilles vax et est ce qu'il y a
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'abstentionnistes
parmi eux moi la manifestation que j'ai
couverte c'était juste après le
ralliement de florian philippot à
nicolas dupont aignan donc laurent
philippot c'était l'ancien colistier
l'ancien bras droit de marine le pen
donc à un ancien de l'extrême droite qui
a lancé son parti les patriots il a
essayé d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle me lapp a recueilli ses
parrainages donc là il a soutenu nicolas
dupont aignan officiellement autour du
thème de la liberté et dans les
manifestations c'est anti vaccin anti
pas sanitaire anti passe vaccinale et
avec beaucoup de slogans et de pancartes
liberté liberté et nicolas dupont aignan
a été parfaitement accueilli par ses par
ces manifestants notamment parce qu'il
en a fait avant d'ailleurs quand
j'interviens florian philippot il disait
que c'était un élément très important
dans sa décision de soutien il l'a vu
avant il s'est pas cachée comme marie le
pen et a donc il a vraiment soutenu
nicolas dupont aignan quand je parlais
par contre aux gens dans la foule on
sentait qu'il y avait un petit
flottement qu'il aurait vraiment préféré
voter pour florian philippot bon si
jamais on leur dit voter pour nicolas du
poignant c'est vrai que c'est le même
combat mais ce qui m'a vraiment frappé
c'est comme tu dis les abstentionnistes
qui alors il y en a qui me disait - jeu
dame je pense que les élections n'auront
pas lieu était persuadé qu'il se
passerait quelque chose qui ferait qui
aurait pas d'élection peut-être on
encore si vous avant de voir si sa
prédiction se réalise mais mais d'ici là
vraiment c'était cette idée de
pourquoi est ce que j'irai m'exprimer
pour là aussi prolonger un système avec
lequel je ne suis pas d'accord avec des
gens qui mentent avant les
abstentionnistes l'une des grandes
raisons c'était que les gens les
politiciens ne répondait pas aux
problématiques des gens sur le terrain
et qu'ils changeaient pas leurs vies
maintenant ils ont tellement
d'informations notamment avec les faits
contenus sur les réseaux sociaux etc que
ils ont l'impression que le gouvernement
carrément les manipulent et donc bah
pourquoi rentrer dans cette danse là
alors une question
qui nous parvient d'ariel régis ou sur
facebook merci beaucoup de nous avoir
écrit ariel de régis sous
marine le pen peut-elle battre emmanuel
macron au second tour c'est vrai que là
ces derniers temps on a des petits
sondages qui tombent ou dans la marge
d'erreur marine le pen
peut peut le dépasser c'est un peu les
derniers sondages qu'on avait sur brick
city 2 a peut-être qu'effectivement le
break site va passer on est au dixième
de point donc il y as et il ya ces
éléments qui font que peut-être après
c'est clairement un sondage auquel car
n'a jamais été aussi aussi sérieux cette
semaine elle a fait alors ce n'est pas
une raie manta da c'est pas ce pas là
jean luc mélenchon c'est
elle était déjà assez haut c'est
clairement la personne la mieux placée
actuellement pour arriver au deuxième
tour les derniers sondages laissent
entendre que sa campagne qui consiste en
partie à se taire et à laisser un exe
moore la rendre plus présidentiable que
ce qu'elle n'était avant c'est
l'achèvement de la dédiabolisation suite
jean marie le pen là c'est vrai que
marine le pen peut peut se targuer de
clairement arrivé au second tour rien
n'est fait encore une fois et peut-être
gagner même si encore une fois on est on
est pas de vin et ça reste reste des
sondages voilà une question de séverin
youmbi toujours sur facebook quand
peut-on espérer qu'une femme devienne
présidente de la république française
bon effectivement la femme en tout cas
qui semble avoir le plus de chances
c'est effectivement marine le pen la
candidate du rassemblement
national et peut-être une dernière
question qui nous parvient de jean
célestin bwaba tshipamba sur facebook
qui demandent à nouveau le nombre total
de candidats et la date du scrutin maya
alors j'ai bien révisé ses longs quiz
avec mon dieu donc il ya douze candidats
est le premier sur le tour c'est le 10
avril voilà c'est en six jours elle
rappelle toujours le dimanche hélas ces
moments je vais me tromper parce que je
me souviens plus le 24 avril j'allais
dire 23-24 ses week-ends 23 24 24 mars
il travaille pas eu un
bon joueur bon merci beaucoup maya
d'avoir répondu aux questions des
internautes sur facebook instagram sur
youtube pour donc ton témoignages et des
reportages je le rappelle sont à
retrouver sur le site internet de france
24 en cash à la fois sur les pages
franco et englos puisque maya est
bilingue merci à vous qui nous
rejoignent et et qui nous ont rejoint
d'ailleurs ces derniers instants sur ce
live de l'émission france 2022 l'heure
du choix on est donc toujours ensemble
pour aller plus loin sur notre émission
répondent à toutes vos questions sur les
grands enjeux de cette présidentielle je
le répète ce live il vous est dédiée
alors continuez à nous poser toutes vos
questions elles sont déjà très
nombreuses je crois que vous nous
écrivez me dit un modératrice
d'abidjan de république démocratique du
congo ou encore de côte d'ivoire merci à
vous tous de suivre cela est vrai et
roselyne febvre est maintenant parmi
nous la chef du service politique de
france 24 salut roselyne je viens écoute
super on est évidemment ravi de t'avoir
à j - 6 du premier tour c'est la
dernière ligne droite
alors tout d'abord peut-être une
question d'emblée roselyne est ce que
les choses sont pliés où sont toujours
ouvertes dans cette dernière ligne
droite non rien n'est jamais plié c'est
ce que en tout cas disent les sondages
c'est vrai qui ne varie pas vraiment les
sondages depuis maintenant des semaines
et des semaines et on voit un emmanuel
macron qu'elle son socle solide même
s'il est en train de s'éroder et marine
le pen qui est solide aussi sur son
socle et puis alors ça ça a changé ce
qui a changé c'est l'écart entre
zemmour mélenchon et valérie pécresse
mélenchon est monté valérie pécresse a
baissé également eric zemmour mais bon
le gérant dire le fond de sauce marine
le pen macro macron plus tôt marine le
pen lui ne bouge pas en revanche il ya
toujours des surprises faut être très
vigilant là dessus 1
on connaît l'expression les vainqueurs
des sondages et les vaincus des
suffrages du coup tu viens de reprendre
en partie à la question de justin
gilloux sur instagram pourquoi aller
voter si nous savons qu emmanuel macron
va gagner donc c'est ce que dit l ail et
pointe il pointe exactement le sujet qui
fait peur à tout le monde c'est
l'abstention et 7 abstentions justement
elle elle vient s'accrocher c'est
justement cette problématique certains
se disent bon bah c'est plié ce soit
macron
et marine le pen donc ça sert à rien on
préfère aller à la pêche à la mouche
plutôt que voilà de
douala de faire changer un scrutin qui
toutes façons et décrit l'avancé
d'avancé mais ce n'est pas vrai et
l'abstention justement ce salon ce
record un électeur sur trois roselyne
pourrait ne pas se déplacer un sur
quatre aussi se dit indécis comment
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là on va ça
fait longtemps que l'abstention s'est
installé dans notre paysage mais c'est
vrai que ce qu'on appelle la mère des
batailles c'est à dire la présidentielle
française généralement elles intéressent
les français alors la participation en
2017 et est de 60
18% 2017 77 tu vois des gens en 2012
donc
elle a augmenté quand même d'un point et
là les sondages disent qu'elle serait
plutôt de l'ordre cette participation de
70% donc une fois de plus ça ça s'érode
de plus en plus parce que parce que pas
confiance dans les politiques de nos
sentiments ba1 ce que ce que tu disais
enfin la question que tu cites est versé
1 c'est déjà plié de ya rien de neuf
sous le soleil voilà on connaît les uns
et les autres on les connaît tous par
coeur et 3 ils sont un peu éloigné de
nos préoccupations donc pourquoi aller
se déplacer c'est toujours un peu ce qui
vient tiraillé
les abstentionnistes mois l'année passée
raconte toujours sur le même thème en
question de audrey et ses serres sur
instagram pourquoi les gens ne vont plus
voter sommes nous toujours des citoyens
dans ce cas
ça c'est la grande question oui on est
bien sûr qu'on ait des citoyens après il
ya des lieux certains pays où le vote
est obligatoire
donc ça c'est une grande question aussi
démocratiques dans la démocratie on a
aussi le droit de pas aller voter
on peut voter blanc
c'est vrai qu'on peut considérer que
c'est un gâchis par exemple certains
pays qui n'ont pas le
où les élections de toute façon sont
truqués ne sont pas les idées mon livre
des urnes sont bourrés
voilà où la démocratie ne fonctionne pas
et nous on se dit on a quand même cet
outil entre les mains de pouvoir faire
changer les choses devaient faire bouger
on ne se déplace pas donc oui j'ai envie
de parler de gâcher aussi way qu'est-ce
que l'abstention va pénaliser est ce
qu'il ya des candidats que ça va plus
pénaliser d'autres mais ça risque de
pénaliser effectivement
celui pour qui on croit que c'est plié
donc forcément la belle macro et
emmanuel macron et puis peut-être aussi
les électeurs de gauche parce que les
électeurs de gauche ceux du parti
socialiste qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
d'enfant est ce que anne hidalgo ils ont
pas envie les ce qui vote social
démocrate on va dire ils n'ont pas envie
d'aller chez chez mélenchon donc tu me
diras le
cercueil parlons d'un hidalgo y ait un
peu et encore des clous au dessus il en
manque un donc si elle a encore de
l'abstention j'ai envie de dire elle va
finir à 1% ou 0 5
donc voila mais non l'abstention elle
elle risque de pénaliser
le candidat sortant est évidemment et
c'est souvent les plus motivés ceux qui
ont envie de renverser la table donc
forcément ceux qui ont envie de
renverser la table basse et ce qui est
qui vote soit zemmour soit marine le pen
soit mélenchon
beaucoup d'adversaires d' emmanuel
macron dénoncé durant toute cette drôle
de campagne l'absence de débat le fait
qu emmanuel macron le président candidat
ne descendez pas dans l'arène et ne
débattait pas donc avec ses adversaires
même le président du sénat ya quelques
semaines donc gérard larcher avait
questionné fin était même allé jusqu'à
questionner la légitimité d'une élection
qui seraient gagnés sans véritable
campagne qu'est ce que tu as pensé
de cette prise de position du président
du sénat une petite question d'ailleurs
de jacques maïder sur instagram qui
rejoint un petit peu ce cette question à
quoi sert cette élection présidentielle
qui semble aujourd'hui n'être qu'un
simulacre de démocratie
est ce que ta pensée de tout d'abord
cette sortie de jarlard et ses
questionnements sur une éventuelle
remise en question de la légitimité du
trouve qu'il a il a gagné une occasion
de se taire parce que d'abord c'est pas
le rôle d'un personnage de l'état si
haut dans la hiérarchie deuxième
deuxième personnage de l'état le
président de la république voilà c'est
pas très
beau c'est que c'est irresponsable et
d'un autre côté n'ont pas la légitimité
pour quoi elle se poserait pas ce que
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de campagne non
la campagne elle a lieu différemment
c'est vrai que c'est un peu morne plaine
mais il ya ulcos vidiella guerre en
ukraine qui asphyxient tous qui écrase
tout donc il ya quand même du débat le
débat il se fait pas la façon dont on
peut l'imaginer avec des grands meetings
on en a vu un pour emmanuel macron est
peu pour les autres
donc non c'est pas il n'y a pas de
question de légitimité c'est une
question on va dire de
voilà deux der du temps qui fait que les
gens ont d'autres chats à fouetter et de
toute façon l'élection elle sera
légitime un non non ce qu'il a il a tapé
à côté là pour le monde autre question
sur facebook d'ibrahim belem quelles
peuvent être les conséquences mois déjà
parlé mais les conséquences de la guerre
en ukraine sur une potentielle
réélection d'emmanuel macron donc en
clair emmanuel macron
va-t-il bénéficié de son rôle de chef de
guerre oui c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet drapeaux alors les on a vu que
l'effet drapeaux ils s'émousser un petit
peu puisque emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
ben il perd il ya sept points d'écart
entre marine le pen et lui donc c'est
vraiment très très serré
c'est difficile à dire c'est vrai qu'au
début de la guerre beaucoup de gens se
sont
se tourner vers la figure on va dire
paternel entre gris mais c'est à dire du
père de la nation c'est à dire celui qui
protège celui qui prend des décisions et
souvent on peut on peut se dire que oui
il connaît les dossiers discute avec eux
la dîmière poutine mais comme ils
n'arrivent pas à grand chose pas faute
d'avoir essayé eh bien il se heurte
forcément un muret à des résultats
[Musique]
donc c'est si difficile c'est difficile
à dire aujourd'hui
en tout cas ça l'a protégé au début de
la guerre je suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui
ce soit vraiment ski ski le ski le
protège autre question de silice en bout
sur facebook pourquoi est ce que cette
campagne accorde autant d'importance à
la question de l'immigration là aussi on
en a parlé dans nos précédents facebook
live mais bon visiblement cette question
revient donc l'immigration c'est moins
le cas ces dernières semaines qu'au
début de l'aquarelle faites-vous faisait
son petit ami reg zemmour
c'est ça sur le 15 et monomaniaque en
tout cas il est social dans les débats
oui un coup cette question là c'est
peut-être beaucoup plus calmes le
pouvoir d'achat non oui alors celle qui
vraiment a eu du nez lèvres du flair
c'est marine le pen puisque dès
septembre elle elle parle du pouvoir
d'achat effectivement avec le démarrage
de la guerre et le prix des de l'essence
elle avait vu juste donc elle à elle a
créé autour d'elle
effectivement un intérêt sur le pouvoir
le pouvoir d'achat
emmanuel macron lui forcément n'en parle
pas beaucoup il en parle entre les
lignes parce que ils seraient accusés
très vite et bien de tourner vers
emmanuel vert marine le pen et zemmour
et c'est d'ailleurs le reproche qu'on
fait à valérie pécresse est d'avoir trop
collé à la ligne ciotti et de virer du
côté de la droite droite droite donc
marine le pen elle sait très bien que
depuis des décennies son père labour est
déjà le terrain de l'immigration tout le
monde sait ce qu'elle en pense et elle
laisse la radicalité à emmanuel macron
elle elle va sur des sujets plus
porteuses et moi j'ai dit quoi et révisé
de mâcon
merci de me reprendre ça prouve que tu
écoutes c'est très bien à azemmour voilà
donc
bon l'immigration cc c'est un sujet qui
est un peu laissé effectivement dans sa
radicalité à eric zemmour question de
niagha dembélé que j'ai posée tout à
l'heure à karina mais je te la repose
est ce que jean luc mélenchon a sa
chance à une chance donc d'être au
deuxième tour peut y avoir une surprise
il peut y avoir une surprise parce que
d'abord je sais pas si tu as vu mais qui
rassemble quand même quasiment autant de
personnes dans la rue qu emmanuel macron
à son meeting donc énormément de monde
et y ait une telle détestation aussi de
maquereau en le vois de gens qui étaient
même à gauche ou qui ont voté pour lui
en 2017 et qui se dit dans le fond il se
fout de nous ils nous baladent la sphère
malkin s'est quand même a eu des
répercussions donc
oui ils montent mélenchon il monte il
monte les a il est à la place du
troisième homme peut-être qu'il n'y aura
une surprise et vous savez c'est là la
difficulté de cette campagne aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya une telle volatilité que
peut-être les gens vont avoir des
pulsions qu'ils n'ont pas aujourd'hui de
se dire ben tiens je vais voter intel et
qui se fera ça se fera dans l'isoloir et
c'est là on peut avoir des surprises
c'est à dire la pulsion de l'isoloir
sous d'où l'intérêt de passes
démobilisés dans la dernière ligne
droite
la pêche même s'il fait beau et tous ces
grands meetings du week-end dernier
autre question ou un peu plus précise de
noura galadima sur facebook comment est
ce qu ils peuvent envisager une retraite
à 65 ans donc en l'occurrence emmanuel
macron et valérie pécresse alors que les
jeunes en france peine à se faire
embaucher merci pour cette question
alors
l'idée sais c'est que d'abord il ya un
problème sur les retraites problèmes
financiers qui est pas très long terme
mais qui à court terme
donc il faut régler le sujet d'ailleurs
le corps le le conseil de l'orientation
des retraites a clairement même si
c'était bourré un moment dans leurs
calculs ce qu'ils avaient et des
maquereaux en quelque sorte à vouloir
faire cette réforme il y a un trou qui
se profile et qui est pour bientôt donc
il faut il faut creuser ce déficit enfin
il faut boucher ce déficit on va dire et
pour sa balle à la solution c'est de
travailler plus longtemps et d'un autre
côté il ya aussi la manière de se faire
d'être
d'être quelque part en conformité aussi
avec d'autres pays européens c'est à
dire qu'on a une une durée de vie qui
s'allonge donc une durée de vie au
travail alors c'est sûr que c'est
toujours le même sujet sur les
travailleurs qui ont un travail
difficile comme les ouvriers sur les
chantiers ou des femmes de ménage ou des
gens qui ont un métier très physique
là dessus se sera comptabilisé
évidemment alors pourquoi les jeunes
n'embauchent pas leurs cils d'ailleurs
les embauches ont augmenté dans le pays
c'est vrai qu'un chômage des jeunes même
s'il est en train de diminuer enfin le
chômage diminue ce qui est plutôt
inquiétant c'est que aujourd'hui bah on
vire les gens quand ils ont 50 55
57 et c'est là qu'il va falloir faire un
travail c'est à dire de garder les gens
te dire ne pas aller à la
poubelle quand ils ont 55 56 57 ans
c'est à dire que de dire c'est ça aussi
c'est ça c'est une discussion à voir
avec les partenaires sociaux et à dire
ok on travaille plus longtemps mais on
vire pas les gens à partir de la
cinquantaine parce qu'ils sont trop
vieux et qu'on veut prendre un jeune
parce qu'il coûtera moins cher pour
faire le même travail donc c'est ça la
problématique
peut-être une dernière question alors
qu'on avait dix questions pièges mais
j'ai pas si tu vas pouvoir
si tu as les chiffres qu'elle est alors
question de sylvain gourmand sur
facebook quel est le candidat qui a le
plus gros budget fois qu'ils dépensent
le plus dans cette campagne
écoute je
je vois ça je peux pas c'est une
question piège j'ai pas si on peut
parler en termes de celui qui dépense
plus ce qui est clair c'est qu'il y
avait marine le pen avait chiffré son
programme il ya quelques jours que
c'était la semaine dernière et on a vu
que c'était un peu pas très sérieux et
qu'elle allait chercher des financements
qui notamment sur le sujet de
l'immigration
qui n'était pas très sérieux
le
peut-être valérie pécresse
va dépenser moins peut-être parce que
vous savez la droite et l'orthodoxie
budgétaire surtout en tout moindre
centime
bah faut qu'on verra ça en fin de compte
non mais celui forcément celui cesser
les extraits les extras l'extrême gauche
extrême gauche c'est la retraite à 60
ans et le smic qu'on augmente ces voix
là c'est un peu on rase gratis quand
même donc à mon avis c'est du côté de
l'extrême gauche du côté de jean luc
mélenchon que l'on dépense le plus
forcément en tout cas ce qu on peut
rappeler c'est que ses dépenses de
campagne ne seront remboursés qu'à
partir du moment où le candidat réalise
5 %
donc mais est-ce qu'on peut là où ils
peuvent peut-être se rassurer c'est
qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de dépenses
parce qu'ils payent beaucoup de meetings
je sais pas s'ils ont dépensé beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent quand on voit emmanuel
macron bon certes c'était un grand
meeting qui a dû coûter très très cher
mais ça a été un meeting les autres
objectivement ils ont fait leur campagne
allaient ils sont allé serrer des mains
dans des villages ou dans des villes
pas beaucoup de papas besoin d'acheminer
des cars entiers de militants qui sont
pas déplacés faute de meeting donc tout
ça s'est fait à la télévision dans la
presse à la radio donc peut-être que là
ils ont ils sentiront pour pas trop cher
merci beaucoup rose et on arrive déjà à
la fin de ce live je te remercie encore
d'y avoir participé
merci aussi à vous tous d'avoir poser
toutes vos questions d'avoir nous avons
écrit tous vos tous vos commentaires
toutes vos remarques on espère qu'on a
répondu au mieux à vos interrogations
sur cette fin de campagne je vous le
rappelle j - 6 avant le premier tour et
d'ailleurs vous pouvez suivre notre
édition spéciale dimanche prochain donc
le 10 avril en compagnie en l'occurrence
de roselyne febvre une édition spéciale
donc pour présenter rafa roselyne et
raphaël cannes pour ma part je vous
donne rendez-vous donc très vite pour un
prochain live ce sera dans l'entre-deux
tours et avant cela rendez-vous bien
évidemment ce soir pour un nouveau
numéro de france 2022 lors du choix à
20h15 heure de paris à tout à l'heure
[Musique]